[Music]
song sounds like she's singing
american idol finalist nikki mckibben
has died
she was 42. her husband craig sadler
shared the heartbreaking news on social
media writing
the love of my life nikki sadler
suffered an aneurysm
on wednesday she would already be gone
but she's an organ donor and has been
kept on life support to make that
possible
that shouldn't be a surprise to us even
at the end she is still giving
how has this changed your life oh like
immensely
everything in my life has changed so far
and i'm just expecting so much more good
stuff in the future that it's all
amazing
craig suggested a sweet way for her fans
to honor nikki posting
she will be taken to the or at three
o'clock am central time to give her
final gift that will save the lives of
strangers
you probably know she practically
worships stevie nicks
before they begin they will play
landslide for her one last time
if you are able you can pause at three
o'clock wherever you
are and listen to it with her she will
know that you're sharing her farewell
[Music]
nicki placed third on american idol's
first season in 2002.
kelly clarkson won the season while
justin guarini was runner-up
i think that america voted him there and
i think they deserve to be there
definitely justin remembered the idol
finalist in a touching post on instagram
calling her a fiery funny lady who would
sing the hell out of a rock song
with the same kind of ease and command
she lovingly used to cut you with
her twingy southern wit american idol
also paid tribute
sharing nicki mckibben was an incredible
talent
and we are deeply saddened by the news
of her passing she was part of our
american idol family and will be truly
missed
ryan seacrest commented on the post
writing nikki was a superstar the moment
she walked into auditions
she set the bar high with her talent and
memorable stage presence
it was an honor to watch her grow and
inspire millions of people
nikki released her first album unleashed
in 2007 and a christmas album
the following year what's your little
boy's name tristan
tristan thanks for being here buddy
[Music]
in 2014 nikki's son tristan competed on
the show and she was there to cheer him
[Music]
on
he made it through the audition round
and nikki was ever the proud mom
it's come full circle isn't it i'm just
so proud
you